you're a fantastic thirty fifty Shades
of Grey movie what do you make a new CV
to get a better job this is versus the
games might show that pits your favorite
games consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against each other this week yeah
we're looking at the much-maligned
sub-genre of film game tie-ins
presenting their cases for the good the
bad and the just plain weird
a Dave Jewett and Oscar Deus who's Sean
Connery impression is just plain awful
the fourth yes well if the girl like
stuff like that it's terrible
last week's fight between Kingdom Hearts
and Final Fantasy saw a resounding win
for Kingdom Hearts with 66% of the vote
well done guys I'm very proud of you and
together we will see this bloody Kingdom
Hearts arca through but to vote for who
you think argued their case better this
week we're gonna be throwing up a
clickable poll right here on YouTube
right let's get into the debate
[Music]
osya hello Dave so because there's not
many games going on now we were talking
about movies summer and it buster season
baby and we're talking about Mission
Impossible fallout that's the topic for
light series oh yeah I've done that I
just destroyed so we thought let's talk
about the movie trying games
admittedly some of the classics might
not have been around when you were alive
but we'll make it work
okay so first we've been doing the best
tying game it's my pick for the best
tying game is Lord of rings return the
King on PlayStation 2 or not it's a
great game and it's it's not only my
favorite maybe tie game but it might be
one of the best movie tie-ins ever it
was real close to the film but also give
gay players a lot of freedom and there
was like three branching paths there was
much wider array of characters you could
play as Gandalf Legolas Arab Legoland
Legoland yeah Windsor it was a couple
more but like I think that the previous
game didn't have nearly as many
characters and each character had its
own either a move set they had their own
skill tree their own advancements you
could customize them to fight in the way
that you wanted to fight in each level
would have a reward system to kind of
encourage replayability and when I was a
kid I played through that game like too
many times for it to really be healthy
to get like Legolas up to level 20 and I
didn't play give me much because he was
like slow and you know screw that little
idiot but if it was actually like an
incredible game the sound design was
amazing the levels were incredible like
they all recreated like the massive
battles from the film and and it made
you feel like in the movie when you're
kicking down ladders off of walls and
like slain Urich I you get an all these
bonuses pop up Oh as nice as all of that
science Dave liking Lord of the Rings
does of course make you a massive nerd
so the best movie tying game there's not
for nerds Jimmy James Michener no it's
actually Lego Star Wars The Complete
Saga
not for nerds yeah
would Star Wars in there yeah point star
was cool
I went for the Complete Saga because
that has all six of the original Star
Wars films and condensed into one game
so you got the best of the original
trilogy and of the prequel trilogy this
is the best thing I think about like
ourselves the prequel trilogy in terms
of the films are obviously derided among
most people the best thing about Lego
Star Wars is that it essentially takes
all of the bad bits I you lose all of
the separatist Trade Agreement [ __ ] that
is so boring like when you're a kid and
you go in the cinema and you're like yes
Star Wars and it's going on about trade
embargoes and you're not what's
happening they didn't even though I
don't buy your was yeah I mean so but
Negus Louis gets rid of all of that and
just goes alright ya have a lightsaber
and fight dudes and like that's amazing
to me and at the same time it gets the
fact that it puts all of those favorite
characters from the prequel trilogy and
from the original trilogy in Lego form
means that you don't have the weird like
uncanny valley bad sound acting a bad
voice acting that you get with a lot of
film tying games because it was all
silent and they managed to get some
really amazing comedy out of scenes that
were already written and acted like 30
years prior to that and at the same time
like you said it is just like a great
game like it has some amazing puzzles in
it and like back then the Lego series
wasn't as kind of formulaic because what
it has sort of become now and it felt
really fresh and I absolutely loved
though all six of those sort of mini
games in themselves and I would
absolutely love to play a remastered
version if they were to do one are you
listening travelers tales worst tie-in
Game Boy I've got a little childhood
story for you settle in picture the
scene right I'm 11 years old
I've not long since just got my ps3
which I'd been looking forward to for
ages the game I got with my ps3 with
spider-man 3 which so I'd already been
burned by the poor film time
I'm really looking forward to Harry
Potter and the order of the field I went
away on a school trip for like three
days and i pre-ordered the game and I
was so excited to get back home I didn't
care right the trip I just wanted to get
back home and play Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix right I wanted to
be in that world because I'd played the
previous Harry Potter and games on like
ps1 and ps2 and loved them love being in
at Hogwarts right and I was so excited
for it and I get back and I put the game
in and it's utter [ __ ]
and I finished it in like must have been
like four hours or something I finished
it that night and this was like the ps3
just come out to the game was like fifty
quid or something there's a lot of money
I was so burned by that I never I never
bought a Harry Potter game ever again I
really enjoyed the the ps2 ones in
particular I thought were really good
like be they made the world of Hogwarts
seem alive and it and it felt like you
living in that were like an open-world
exploring the castle exactly which is
all you want when you're a kid you're
like I wanna be at Hogwarts right and
this just didn't do that at all
it wouldn't made it so lifeless and just
got all the characters just seemed so
like wooden see mine is as you've heard
a street fighter I have heard of Street
Fighter yes good series games here the
movie mm-hmm bad bad movie right but
there is a street fighter the movie the
game is that yes they based as the best
movie off the original game and they
based an entirely different game which
played completely differently of the
terrible movie it was so bad like okay
so just just at the core it was a bad
fighting game had bad framerate it just
played terribly it wasn't it wasn't it
didn't feel like a street fighter game
they took they took the images of
jean-claude van Damme and Kylie Minogue
and they sucked them in this fighting
game it was so janky and you just saw I
it must've been a long day in the Foley
studio where they had to tell Jean
Claude Van Damme to start making like
damage sounds it's Kylie Minogue's in it
hey listen he is a great actor alright
and to be able to play as her in a video
game
I would absolutely welcome that all
right the last topic is our guilty
pleasure the game that I have very fond
memories of was the die hard
trilogy on ps1 Oh God so they had they
made the die hard trilogy after all the
films that come out so you had one two
and three and what was amazing about it
is that die hard one was like a 3d
shooter where you're exploring Nakatomi
Plaza and Resident Evil style like tank
controls you can pick up new guns
grenades armor taking down terrorists
number two this is a bearing in mind
that's what I had one plate number two
is a light gun game sweet again like new
weapons new power-ups the environments
were destructible if people were
standing under stuff you could shoot out
like lights to make them full of people
I loved playing that game and so that
number three is like a crazy taxi sort
of game you're in either a cab or a
sports car or a dump truck and you're
racing around New York City in a kind of
racing game my campaign objectives
disarming bombs getting to checkpoints
at the same time so they were all there
give me three completely different
flavors for three complete like differs
a film it was it was fascinating like if
you liked a little small was bored of
genres I know but they were only they
were only ever between an hour and two
hours that's fine I know those bite
sizes you could again replay my one is
From Russia With Love which was a weird
anomaly when EA made that in the news
2005 because they had like loads of
games of Brosnan series yeah exactly
they were like now we're gonna go all
the way back to Russia With Love exactly
I think it was basically in that period
between Brosnan and Craig that they were
like oh we've gotta make a bond game
because they make money we've got the
license what we're gonna do so they just
made a Sean Connery won and like they
got some Connery actually back in to
record the voice lines and - yeah and he
completely like he just he's playing
Sean Connery in this he doesn't play
Bond it's like full Scottish accent like
the full yes we're all like stuff like
that it's terrible
but it somehow is just so satisfying to
be able to play a game of a film that
I'd watch so many times because I'm a
huge table on family night and I've got
the entire series and it was so awesome
to be able to play as Sean Connery it
was the first time he played bond in
like 35 year 34 years he didn't play but
he played him cash it in a check yeah
Land Rover yes so yeah it's a bit more
shooter II than a bond game I feel
should be but like it was also ahead of
its time as well I had some of their
like disguise uniform mechanics that are
seen in like the modern hitman game oh
yeah like this was like 13 years ago
there was something about it that was
just so satisfying to be able to be in
that bond world but set in the 60s you
know it's like a period Bond film and I
absolutely adored it they're all the
bond games are good except for
double-oh-seven legends sorry you just
go it's a bunch of fun gameplay just
like yes I'm perfectly up for that I
love that this is work let us know who
you think won by voting in our poll and
the top right at the corner if you're
watching on youtube or if you're over on
gamespot.com
by putting your thoughts in the comment
section below right time for this week's
quickfire round a series of dumb fun
questions written by the rest of the UK
team let's see how Dave and Oscar get on
what's your dream film tying game and
who would make it I just want a film
tie-in game made for every single Bond
film and just give them all no they
wouldn't
they'd all be amazing give them all to
know we talk or I'll tell you what Alpha
Protocol for bond yes I'd be sick
picture most shameless cash-grab idea
for a tying game ah at the minute if
they if they went back and made the
Japanese battery I'll fill into a game
dad make bank do an impression of the
worst line of dialogue you know from a
film tired so there's a bit in From
Russia With Love where they got Sean
Connery in to play Bond again obviously
and at the very beginning of the game
it's like the girl gets stolen away by
the bad guy
and he says this this is the end bond
and then bond goes I think it's just a
begun or something and it's like that's
right at the very beginning of the game
and it's so bad that it's so poorly
delivered because Sean Connery is
massively phoning it in ooh bad the game
is all that Mr Bond I think it's just
begun you're at a fantastic thirty fifty
Shades of Grey movie what do you make a
new CV to get a better job
press X to wit middle-aged moms are
gonna be playing it's got to be a mobile
game in it yeah definitely be a mobile
game it would just be it just be a porn
game that's fine pong games are a thing
oh then that bombshell let's go in yeah
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argued their case
better and if you enjoyed this episode
of vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button as we have new episodes of the
show every Wednesday thanks for watching
see ya
[Music]
you